hello everyone and welcome to the final
game of around 6
we agreed to show it's Vladimir Kramnik
versus Vasily one Chuck and as I said in
my previous video it's a really intense
game where a bunch once again gets into
time trouble it's like this is the sixth
game in this tournament he got in the
time trouble and Vladimir Kramnik goes
all out so it's a it's a very exciting
game and before we actually see it let's
check out some of the photos we have
from this tournament from this round
here we have a Vasily von Schuch a nice
follow him seemingly channeling his
energy into that light square bishop and
c8 preparing to use it later also we
have a very nice photo
it seems that kramnik and Devon took are
both looking at something on the on the
other floor and it's interesting you can
see that Vladimir Kramnik has a glass of
water and eventually doesn't this is
this is pure psychological warfare as
you want to be is telling you a kramnik
that he can take him on without any
refreshments and here we have a nice
photo of event row from the opening you
know just a nice photo of event took so
that being said let's see this wild game
and we do have the standings after round
6 since this is the final game of run 6
but that will also be shown after the
game d6 we have a knight to f6 c4 e6
Knight to f3 and d5 so the Queens gambit
declined g3 Bishop to b4 check better up
to d2 and now Bishop back to d6 Bishop
to g2 Knight B to d7 and we have castles
castles and Queen to c2 c6 Knight to c3
D captures on c4 and the rook F to d1
Queen to c7 and here economy goes nice
to g5 and Knight to g5 you you think why
play such a silly move you want you can
simply play h6 and kick away this night
that's true but if you play h6 kramnik
will play Knight to e4 and now instead
of having a knight on f3 chromic has a
knight on e4 and e4 is a square somewhat
more active than f3 so this is in fact
improving the position of this Knight
and you want to push h6 but it's not a
useful move and in general you don't
want to push a pawn unless unless it
really gives you something because once
you push a pawn you can never undo so
after Knight to g5 Bishop to e7 a for
grabbing some space on the Queen side
also not allowing b5 we have E 5 and now
a 5 grabbing even more space he captures
on d4 and now a nice in-between move
Bishop to f4 this comes with an attack
on the Queen also opens up the attack to
this pawn Bishop to d6 now comes Rock
capture son before Bishop captures and
rook captures and it's a it's somewhat
somewhat a silly Square for the rook you
might think but it's it's actually
perfectly fine black doesn't have a dark
square bishop and this rook will be one
of the main actors of this game if I
push this h6 now he does kick away the
knight Knight to f3 and now event you
should come up with a plan he still has
to develop his light square bishop he
has to develop this rook this rogue also
has to come into play and one one idea
as Kramnik did push this a pawn all the
way to a5 would be nice to be eight with
ideas of knife to a6 coming all the way
to b4
but if I chooses a different idea after
Knight to f3 he goes for the active b5
and this gives cronic a very nice idea
chronic plays a capture some b6 um
Poisson of course now you can't
recapture with the pawn because the rock
would be hanging and I ate so Knight
captures now this Bishop is able to come
into play and here comes a move that
starts a very nice attack for Vladimir
Kramnik and it's actually the strongest
more recommended by the engine but it
doesn't give a white all that much it's
just just move you really have to play
rook captures on f6 so just giving up
the exchange and it's very interesting
how chronic approaches the game after
this exchange sacrifice so G captures on
f6 and now something we caught all off
and said after after you make a
sacrifice don't don't think you have to
go all out immediately go crazy you know
you have to enjoy the moment that you
just sacrificed a piece and just
continue on playing the game so no
nothing crazy simply nice to d4 it was
an exchange sacrifice
you know for positional purposes now you
improve the position of your knight you
open up your light square bishop now
you're attacking the c6 pawn and later
after black deals with this only then
will you continue with your plan
so first Evangelos Bishop to d7 defends
the c6 pawn and now comes Queen to d2
with Queen captures on h6 this is of
course the idea now you do have to
defend this pawn you can either do it by
King g7 you can do it by King h7 if you
go King h7 then rook to a5 will be a
very nice idea and after this rook comes
to h5 then this King and H zone will be
blocking for example rook to h8 black
will not have this resource of defending
the pawn so event to defend that with
King to g7 and now this is one of the
moment that even chronic said even
though event was already here this is
move 21 he was in time trouble but here
chronic took a very forcing variation
that doesn't really give him all that
much you should continue with rook to a5
and then transfer the rock all the way
here and then try just increasing the
pressure but here he played the bishop
captures on c6 even though this is
protected twice so first an exchange
sacrifice and now a chronical goes for a
piece sacrifice Bishop captures on c6
and now of course not recapturing but
rather Knight to f5 now that Bishop
captures and c6 is no longer defending
the f5 square so it's very dangerous
it's the king is in check the Queen is
also a eyeing the h6 pawn what do you do
here well if you go King to g8 then
after Queen captures here there's really
no defense against the Queen to g7
checkmate but white is completely
winning here
so after this Knight to f5 move Chucky's
goes for for a very nice idea and it's I
mean King to g6 and after you make a
move like this we really need to address
the elephant in the room I mean what
happens after Queen captures on h6 can
the King really come to f5 well Queen
captures King to f5 and let's let's look
at what's going on here
the knight is covering these squares the
pawns are covering these squares the
Queen is covering these
so as you can see the King doesn't have
all all that many squares he can walk on
but black is actually perfectly fine
here and white would not have anything
better here than a perpetual Queen to h3
now we have to go back King to g6 and
now white and simply continue Queen g4
and here for a perpetual and even if you
don't
for example after King captures on f5
even if you try to improve with
something to maybe start pushing your
pawns or something black will simply try
and run away immediately so after after
you prevent this
then comes Rock h8 and after Queen
checks Queen to e5 black the defense and
white doesn't really have a way to
continue so after King to g6 there is no
Queen to h6 resource so first Cromley
goes rook to a5
now the knight is defended and now there
definitely is a threat of Queen captures
on h6 so once again what do you do here
well in the game rook to h8 was played
and this is a very nice move guarding
the pawn queen to d4 and what is crumb
mix idea kramnik wants to play Queen to
g4 check for example if if something
like Queen to d7 is played you wanna
exchange Queens then Queen to g4 of
course will be very powerful King h7 and
then Queen to g7 this will be checkmate
so a nice idea this Queen to d4 one
problem is if you wanna if you want to
stop Queen to g4 you can't do it with h5
okay there's that dust-up Queen to g4
but there there's an even greater idea
here white is completely winning here
and it's a very nice attacking puzzle
for you to solve so I will give it a
couple of seconds it's a really nice one
do do try and solve it so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are once again an
excellent attacker and for those who
just want to enjoy the show
the move is nice h4 check King to g7 you
have to defend the f6 pawn with the king
and now comes the move you had to find
rook to g5 check as the f6 pawn is
pinned
King moves and now comes Queen captures
on f6 the threat of course is Queen
captures on h8
and there's really nothing I can do here
after you stop it then comes the rock
captures captures and then Knight to f5
threatening Queen g7 checkmate and
there's nothing to do if you try and run
away then Queen to h8 will be checkmate
as the knight is covering both a7 and g7
so a wild position and especially for
revenge of who is in time trouble he has
to defend extremely properly and you
know unfortunately for Vladimir Kramnik
he does rook a to g8 now now if Queen to
g4 then the King can come to h7 and this
Rock will be attacking the Queen so
white will not be able to continue
anything immediately so rook the c5 now
pinning this bishop and what do you do
here well Queen to d7 was played in the
game Queen to f4 and now comes H 5 H 5
now does work we have an i to h 4 check
King the g7 and Knight to f5 repeating
the position again with check and here
if one chick has to make a choice as he
is in time trouble thus he repeat into
g6 or does he go King to f8 let's see
what happens if came to f8 if King to f8
then comes Queen to be a to check the
knight is covering the is still covering
a 7 and g7 so you can't really move the
King you have to block this night here
and now comes Queen to b4 threatening
all sorts of discoveries after this rook
moves as the Queen and King are aligned
on this diagonal after something like a
5 it's a very hard move to find
especially if you're in time trouble
then comes this with check and after
Knight blocks again white can simply
check Knight c8 and Queen before check
and so on and so on so this is this is
just one annoying variation for black
that happens if jockey after Knight to
f5 decides to go King to f8 so here you
want to didn't go to f8 he went with
went king to g6 and now Aladdin
electronic repeated King 2h a nitro H
for check King to g7 and Knight to f5
check so after a three-fold repetition
of the position the players agree to a
draw so after after a very
in st. battle and event once again for
the sixth time a game in a row being in
time trouble and two of the games in
this tournament he already lost on time
because the clock ran out it's very
funny what Vladimir Kramnik said in an
interview after this game that you know
his unfortune event in the previous
games had like maybe 5 seconds to make
15 more moves to reach 9 control but in
this game he had like like a minute and
the minute was enough for him so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and let's check out some of the photos
we have after after this game was played
here it is and this is this is a this
and the second photo I really enjoy so
this is Yvonne Chow and Kramnik after
this game analyzing the position and
asking Fritz all of the variations they
they saw they missed and look at how how
they're how they're enjoying it they
just played like like a 5 hour game and
this is this is why people love chess
and we don't have another excellent
photo here it is look at the chronic now
that that is someone who truly enjoys
what he's doing and handi-van trick also
so if anyone ever tells you you know
chest the chest is just as boring just
isn't a lot of fun just just show them
this photo of Yvonne chicken chronic
analyzing their game after just just
playing it for the past 5 hours and so I
don't forget let's check out the
standings after round 6 so these are the
standings the standings are completely
the same as I have to round 5 cross in
first place at I'd of 11 Oregon with
four and a half Peter Svidler with three
Vladimir Kramnik with three then our job
with two and a half Grisha with two and
a half and then in last place and
Gelfand with one and a half and lastly
one Chuck with one and a half so yeah
those were the standings I do hope you
enjoyed that and for those of you who
are you know insane Boris Gelfand fans
we do have another nice photo of Gelfand
as we're not going to shock his game
against Greece Chuck from this round it
was a pretty quick draw so let's see it
there we have it - before the game
preparing or doing
what but it's a very nice photo so yeah
for the end of this video I would like
to thank dynamic all of raymond young
with Montes de lys actor zebra and I've
made a large for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see as soon with
another video from this tournament 2013
candidates from around 7:00 and this is
the last round and then we go into into
the second you know second half of the
tournament so yeah that's it have a
pleasant rest of the Saturday and I will
see you soon thank you